how does film negotiation work
so usually if a distributor wants a film
um they'll reach out with terms
um either you know everybody does a
little bit differently some people
um will poke at me and say well what do
you want
um some will just send me an email
saying
um okay here's the here's what we would
do for the film here's the distribution
fee and then either they have a
a term sheet or they just type it into
an email
um
usually the next step is I present that
to my filmmaker
um
explain the company to them and what
what they're about
introduce them to them so they can hear
from the horse's mouth so the
distributor can tell them exactly what
they're going to do with the film and
how much they like the film Etc
and then we repeat that process with any
other offers coming in
and then I usually try to help the
client make a decision in terms of which
way they want to go
and then depending on which way they
want to go there are some Distributors
that have come at us exactly where they
want to be and I just know from
experience there's no negotiation
they've come at me with the lowest
distribution fee they ever offer the
lowest cap on expenses they'll do the
lowest term they'll do and
um and then there are some companies I
know that they've come at me a little
higher than what they'll do and I know
what the wiggle room is ahead of time
um and so depending on who the client is
chosen I'll tell them okay well here's
where I think we can move the contract
on this
if they give me the green light then I
usually call the distributor and say hey
here's they like you best but only if uh
you can make these terms
um and then if they agree then we're
good and we go to a long form and then
there's a long form to negotiate as well
but usually I've seen most of the long
forms for all the companies that I've
dealt with and some of them I've
redlined before and already got a pound
of Flesh and I know exactly what they're
gonna you know what they're gonna agree
to or not so there really is no need to
get into that in order to make the deal
we can just make a deal based on the
deal memo or the email
and then um and then worry about the
long form after the fact
um
and if they don't come if they don't
agree to whatever I'm proffering in
terms of a counter I go back to the
client say well they wouldn't go down do
you want to
you want to try them again or you want
to respond to their counter to our
counter or do you want to go given that
do you want to try the other person
because maybe they're more amenable and
maybe you like them more now that you've
heard that they won't do what you want
to do and so then um I'll go and but
usually only negotiate with one at a
time
um it's just you don't negotiate with
two entities at the same time because if
they both accept you if you give them if
you counter both of them they both said
yes then you've um you've committed
fraud so you don't want to do that it's
the only deal with one at a time until
there's an acceptance of an offer then
you then you have a deal
and sorry a term sheet is what
a term sheet usually
um
um is just a either piece of paper or a
PDF that has the basic terms of an
agreement not all the language of the
agreement
so it'll spell out usually a term sheet
will have the length of the contract
the rights the maybe not all the
like it'll say
um video on demand rights DVD and
Blu-ray rights advertising video on
demand rights it's what rights they're
taking
but it won't have a description of each
right which will be in the long form
agreement
it'll have the term
um it'll have the
um if there's a minimum guarantee that
they're going to pay against the rights
against against the revenues then
that'll be in the term sheet
um and then
beyond the major things
um the depending on the distributor they
might have
um how the you know just a quick couple
lines on how they do accounting a quick
quick couple lines on expenses and
whether they cap them or not
and so there might be a couple things to
flesh out in the term sheet depending on
how specific or or not specific term
sheet is
um before we go to long form to make
sure okay we don't want to agree to this
because there's a little ambiguity in
the term sheet in terms of like
accounting rights so let's be sure that
what we mean here is quarterly for two
years not just or quarterly for the
whole time or what you want to be you
know as specific as possible before you
say yes
um but some of that I already know
because I've seen their long forms
before so we can we can work off just
the basic terms in order to make it a
deal
so it's almost like a cliff notes yeah
for the okay and then the long form is
is how many pages usually
it depends on the distributor
um some it can be
five or six pages
some it can be 26 30 pages
um some of them have agreements where
they have kind of the basic terms in the
first three or four pages
and then what's called the standard
terms and conditions document that's
kind of stapled to it that kind of gets
into the nitty-gritty of everything
defining all the terms defining all the
rights and all those things
so
um
it depends it depends on the company to
a certain degree how lengthy it is
and what what is the usual the standard
length of term
or does it vary depending on it does
vary the the range is 3 to 15.
oh Years Years
um
you do you do see 20 even from bigger
deals
but they're plunking down a lot of money
they're really making it their film
um
I would say most of my deals are in the
seven year range
usually we're negotiating down from 15
to 7. but then there are a couple
companies that are more aggressive and
do like three years
um
but you find that all companies have an
executive there that's like well we
never do below three years or we never
do below seven it had their own standard
that they just won't you know they just
won't go below because
and I find that most companies that
want longer terms
the reason they want longer terms or a
couple one is
they have these big libraries and they
want if new ways to release films come
out on the market they want to have this
huge library of films that they can
monetize that new way so for instance
advertising video and demand or avod is
relatively new platform
so all these companies that had all
these movies suddenly had a whole nother
way to monetizing these films and if
they had only had three years
there'd be four or five years of films
that they didn't have to put through
this these platforms
um
another reason is it looks better on
your books to have long terms so if
someone's evaluating of a bank is
evaluating your company
um if you're trying to sell it to
someone and you have you know 20 films
for three years
they're like well geez in three years
you this is nothing you know like so and
if and you're not gonna be able to
monetize it with a new uh platform that
comes around like like if avod you know
or something like it
um so
um their assets on the books of these
Bank of these companies the banks just
value them more if they have longer
terms on their contracts interesting and
is it reasonable to expect the longer
the terms of the contract the more or
the possibility of an advance
no not really
um
well um I should say maybe
the the companies that are doing three
years are not doing advances yeah so I
guess I guess yes is actually the answer
to that question so the companies are
doing 7 10 15 years are more likely to
do advances
um
and I think that's I think that's
because they just don't have to be as
aggressive as the three-year
they're usually offering a little bit
more than the companies that are doing
three years they have a longer they've
been around longer
um they might be doing theatrical on
some of their movies they just have you
know bigger pipeline
um
yeah they're a little bit more they're
not having to be as aggressive
to get films than the companies that are
doing the three-year terms
movies that I've watched on TV these
were all films that have been out for 20
plus years so yeah that makes sense yeah
it would be the case for you know
wanting them to on their I don't know
they want them on their books but
establish names from filmmakers that
have been around yeah exactly why does
slam dance co-founder and filmmaker Dan
mervish call you a shrewd negotiator
um because I paid him okay all right
that's good I
um uh Dan's a great friend I I met him
early on in the in the days of slam
dance
um because I think I attended the second
slam dance
um and been going ever since
and I've had
every year I have two to four movies at
slam dance
and then at some point it struck up a
friendship with Dan's been so long I
don't remember when
and then um
I remember even when he you know when he
was going around with his second film
I read it gave him some comments on it I
don't think anything to do with that one
and then later on I've sold a couple
I've sold now two films for him and kind
of consulted him on another one
and um and Dan's a very you know Dan is
a little much more knowledgeable than
your average Indie filmmaker
um so he's
definitely a big part of the process
when I'm helping when I when I have
helped him sell a film and
um
and so there's a shorthand there too and
so I think he I think more than anybody
he knows a little bit more than my
average client what I know
um and how helpful I can be and so
like like I said there are some people
like you know Dan Dan could probably
take the time and do what I do and get
everybody to watch the film
it might it might take longer because he
he's not doing it year round like I am
and I think that's why any and because I
stare at it I know all these things he
knows by experience what I know
um
and um
and yeah then it comes in negotiation
um that's fun because it's uh we we go
back and forth in terms of like how
we're going to try to
um influence the buyer that he likes to
do do the best by it so
how do you negotiate the best deal for a
movie
um
well
to a certain degree
um
I you know I think that
most films I'm working on are going to
this certain level of distributor and
there's only a certain range that we're
going to be negotiating
and I already know going in
what the best position that these
negotiations will do for really any film
if it hits that range
so there's some films where
um
I just know exactly where they'll go
I know where they won't go and it's it's
more about communicating the filmmaker
like you hear your hear your options
here's how we can kind of push a little
bit or pull a little bit
um
it does get more interesting when
it's a it's a it gets above that level
and we're getting theatrical offered
and
um
and I I find that
um it's best to go to Distributors with
the position of hey they really want to
be with you but here's what you got to
do
um I'm not a fan of like you know saying
well so and so wants it you know are you
going to beat them
um I'm not a fan of um
um
telling people what we want upfront
usually if it Disturbia comes to me and
says well what do you want I'm saying I
usually say we want the best possible
deal
um because I don't want to undersell it
you know I want them to come to me with
the best possible thing
um there's a little bit of that
um
I guess I've been doing it so much and
so I I don't find it that complicated a
lot of it's intuitive
um and a lot of it's just knowing
knowing who I'm dealing with pretty well
and
um and knowing where they'll go and
where they won't
so you're not trying any well you know
if you don't let us know in five days I
have X Y and Z over here that they want
it and you know you'd be crazy to lose
out in this doesn't work yeah it just
doesn't
[Music]
um
and especially since I'm you know I mean
maybe if I was just a one-off
person that they didn't know me
and had no history of dealing with me
but almost everybody I'm selling films
to I've sold two films for a couple
decades you know so
um
it's uh there's it's there's it's a lot
more
um
it's a lot more straightforward and like
like this is really the you know I also
know since I know where they'll
potentially go I know where they won't
go
I know not to go to them with
something crazy that they won't do
um
and I have it in situations where
filmmaker is like well push them anyway
you know like hey you know they won't
pay in advance but ask for one anyway
and I'll do it I don't care
um but I'm always right I mean they're
they're not going to you know they're
not going to do what I know they're not
going to do
um
I don't think I've ever been surprised
that way
um another rule of thumb there is that
if someone's you know if someone's made
an advance offer an mg offer then
they're probably movable on it a little
bit
if if but not not a hundred percent
greater than what they've offered so
they've offered you twenty thousand
they're probably not going to 40. they
might go to 25 or 30. that that's a
generalization
if they offered nothing
they're probably not offering anything
they're probably not moving even to one
thousand dollars because that's just not
the way they see it this transaction
so it's just knowing those things I
think that helps
the negotiation
so you you pretty much know the rules of
the game the players in the game and
where those films are going to plug in
and there's probably not a lot of leeway
like you said if someone's not going to
give a minimum guarantee they're
probably not going to do a thousand or
Twenty Thousand for one right exactly
um that's not to say I am surprised by
who wants what though
and it's not like I like I'm
I'm selling the film right now to HBO I
didn't know HBO was going to want the
movie
um or pay a good license fee for it I
had no idea
um and my my next best offer was not
even close
to what they offered so it's not that I
know it's going to happen I just know
once they make the offer I know
I know where where they'll go where they
won't go
how often are these negotiations in
person and how often are they via email
Skype yeah they're all a combination of
zoom and and email and phone
um even pre-covered
um overwhelmingly unless you're
selling film at Sundance
um they were selling a film with
Sundance or South by Southwest and it's
in person then you're going to a condo
and you're meeting meeting people in
person
um
if um there have been times though I
guess
there are occasions though where I have
had filmmakers go to meet distributors
in Los Angeles
um as part of the process you know
pre-covid
um but I don't need to be there because
I'm just putting them together to meet
in order to talk creative and what they
do for the film
um and then the negotiation will happen
by phone or or by email afterwards
because so much of it needs to be in
writing
yeah there's just no reason to get
together you know like there's no reason
to get in a car and drive 30 minutes to
just do what you can do
um pretty you know more efficiently by
by phone or email
can you explain the deal memo
um Dillman was a turn sheet
at the end of the day so Dil memo is the
basic terms of a deal
um the term the length of the the
contract the minimum guarantee if
they're going to pay something up front
for the movie The number of years the
rights they're going to take and then
some of the other factors that they
every demo is a little bit or term
sheets a little bit different in terms
of what they'll
um they'll put out there in terms of
what they are you know the it's kind of
a it's like you said earlier Cliff Notes
version of the contract okay sorry I
didn't realize the deal number was the
same thing yeah it's a term okay maybe
you said that okay without naming names
what's the worst distribution deal
you've seen a distributor offer one of
your films
um
question
well certainly not one that I ever would
allow someone to take
um
it usually
when I see a bad one it has to do with
how revenues are shared
and they're just the Distributors just
taking too much
um
there are some deals where
there's some Distributors out there
that use other Distributors to get their
films out into the marketplace
um and so
they're taking a percentage
after
the distributor who's doing the work is
taking a percentage after iTunes has
taken a percentage
right so I went from iTunes to
distributor to distributor to you
and some Distributors small these are
smaller companies don't disclose it
and say Hey you know this is our
distribution fee but just so you know
we're also going through this other
company
there are companies though that do
legitimately and say okay this is our
distribution fee and it's inclusive of
the Distribution Company that is
actually doing the work that getting it
out there
or they'll say it is on top of and yes
it's a big fee but but that's what we
that's the way we do it this is a little
bit more legitimate than hiding it right
so the worst deal is is the combination
of the fact that it's fee on top of a
fee and they're not revealing they're
just going to give you a royalty
statement that says what came in
and what they took from it without
explaining that another level of Revenue
went from one person to another person
that came to them
if that makes sense
why would a filmmaker even I mean why
would a company even think that a
filmmaker would entertain
it's like an extra middle man that's not
just a middle man it sounds like a well
again some people don't reveal it and
they don't know that's the familiar
doesn't know that's the question uh
right and
um okay there I do know one company that
will reveal it if you ask them
but they don't reveal it if they don't
if you don't ask them
which and it's just really strange
because I like without naming names I
like a lot of things about these people
they're really they do other things kind
of right but that one aspect of it I
like
why why like and I guess it's because
probably because they're not winning
movies
because they have to re that when they
do reveal that some filmers are like
well I can't give you a percentage on
top of another percentage
um and I know another company though
that what they figured out to do is to
make the company that they go through
have their fee inclusive of their fee so
the fee that they're proffering it might
be more like 30 35 because they're
having to account for giving 15 to
someone else but at least
you know it's it's more competitive
than charging 25 on top of 20. right
um
so you do get different kinds out there
but
overwhelmingly most of my films
all
almost all of my films
almost 100 go through companies that
there's just one fee being paid taken
out
um
there's
there's one distributor I go through
who takes a fee but has it inclusive of
this company he's going through and he's
a
he's an honorable X Studio guy who was
very straightforward about what he does
and essentially the way the the
conundrum the Distributors that people
have when they become a dis they want to
become a distributor is how do I get to
Market
right because anybody I could go
tomorrow and say hey I'm a distributor
you give me the movie and I go put it on
iTunes through a lab I just pay the
encoding fee real easy
what's harder is to sell it to cablevod
and to establish a distribution
relationship with the streamers and
established relationship with 2B and the
other advertising video on demand
companies
that's harder to do
and so what some people decide is hey I
want to distribute movies but I don't
have those relationships I'll create a
partnership with a bigger company I'll
go to the cost of acquiring and
marketing the movies and we'll just have
a relationship with this company where
they are the ones who put it on the
platforms and do the sales
and that's fine
if you're above board about it
and your fee isn't too and you're able
to do a fee structure that that doesn't
take too much out of the dollar
but if it's if you don't reveal it
quasi-criminal to me
um it's not criminal but it's
very unethical
um and
um
and then and then just the fee structure
is just crazy you know like if you do a
fee on top of fee it's just like how do
you how do you make any money
it's very hard
so if a filmmaker was doing the DIY
wearing the distribution hat themselves
and and they've been approached or they
approached someone and they don't
realize this is not that there's not
just one Phoebe how are they going to
uncover that what kind of clues or paper
trail or how are they going to do a
search
to see so
um
some platforms like Amazon and others
have in the details of the film they'll
have like the copyright date and a
little bit of information and some of
them have the distributor name
and so if the distributor isn't your
distributor
most likely they put it through somebody
else oh wow right but that would be too
late at that point oh yeah
yeah
there's a there's a
um
there are definitely a lot of there are
a lot of companies that
just don't do it
properly one way or another
um and I just don't send them my movies
it's showing me easily easily handled
that way sure it's real fun you know
it's sort of this omitting very
important information yeah interesting
so that it would be very difficult until
you get to a point where you can't even
get out of the contract it sounds like
yeah I mean like I said like
distribution contracts are hard to get
out of
they're not they're not built to be easy
to get out of
and um
especially if you're working with
someone
who didn't tell you everything up front
about how they do business
most likely they don't really care if
you want to get out either
right that's the kind of person they are
so
um
that's why it's very important
if if you are diying it if you are going
to distributors
or producer reps or anybody you should
be checking IMDb and calling those
filmmakers and and trying to get enough
of them to tell you what their
experiences were so that you can make a
you know a little bit of an educated
decision on on where to go sure and even
in doing that you can still run into
problems
100 so people know each other they could
be friends they could have alliances
yeah it's real tricky but yeah that's
interesting I I did not know that yeah
for for filmmakers that um
you know because in that that there's a
bigger chunk being taken out because
there's this extra person that's right